[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
édition du 7 8 week end sur tv soixante
dix huit éditions spéciales aujourd'hui
consacrer entièrement à la semaine de la
presse et des médias à l'école à cette
occasion nous avons voulu donner la
parole aux collégiens ou lycéens des
yvelines vous découvrirez dans un
instant leur reportage
ils nous parleront de sport jeux vidéo
de cyber sécurité ou encore de
géopolitique
ce sont des classes situées à conflans
sainte honorine et à mantes la ville qui
ont travaillé sur cette édition et puis
également en fin d'émission nous
échangerons avec des élèves de bts pour
garda vont connaître pardon leur regard
sur les médias
[Musique]
pour débuter cette édition nous allons
retrouver les élèves du collège la
vaucouleurs c'est un manque la ville
labellisée classe médias par l'académie
de versailles de classe travail de 4e
il travaille chaque semaine sur le
décryptage de l'information et ils
échangent avec un journaliste basé au
nigeria
notre classe est parrainée par les
journalistes gomis qui est en résidence
au nigeria il réalise des reportages
pour de grands médias français et
internationaux comme rfi france 4 ou
encore arte il nous accompagne depuis le
début de cette aventure est venu
échanger avec nous régulièrement partage
son quotidien de journalistes au nigeria
quelles sont les conditions d'exercice
du métier de journaliste dans les zones
à risque nous avons demandé à notre pas
en nourrice gomis de répondre à quelques
questions
bonjour morize pouvez vous nous dire
quels sont les risques du métier de
journaliste bonjour
de manière générale est journaliste quel
que soit l'endroit dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est pas quelque chose
c'est super simple parce que on fait ce
métier là et qu'on essaye de décrire des
réalités parfois on va heurter des
intérêts du pays des intérêts privés
on va déranger fait un petit journalisme
est grand comme un petit chien avec
plein plein de réalité c'est très
compliqué et et est obligée de de
prendre des précautions pour toi qu'avez
vous ressenti à la première fois que
vous avez fait un reportage dans une
zone à risque
avez vous déjà eu peur pour vous bon
souviens très bien c'était en 2000 en
2015 dans le nord du nigeria vie qui
s'appelle canaux y avait eu un attentat
à la bombe dans la grande mosquée en
victime tu sens quand même une montée
d'adrénaline quand on part dans une zone
comme ça un peu à risque le maître mot
c'est la préparation on prépare son
voyage
on prépare ses déplacements on prépare
ses rendez vous
france 24 et rfi pour lesquelles je
travaille me laisse pas partir s'il ne
leur dit pas à l'avant ce qui je vais
voir où je vais comment j'y vais et
pourquoi j'ai dit tout un travail à
faire avec ma réaction
que vas y mon déplacement selon
reporters sans frontières
il ya eu 50 journalistes mort de leur
métier et 400 journalistes emprisonnés
en 2020 la semaine de la presse et des
médias à l'école 32e édition s'achève
donc comprendre le système des médias
formée le jugement critique des élèves
de la maternelle au lycée ou encore
développer leur goût pour l'actualité
les enjeux sont multiples cette année
nous avons vous le voyez décidé de
donner l'occasion à plusieurs classes
impliquée via leurs enseignants de
préparer leur propre reportage ce sont à
présent des élèves du lycée jules ferry
de conflans sainte honorine qui nous
parle de cyber sécurité ils sont
inscrits en bts services informatiques
aux organisations l'attaquent la plus
fréquente que les personnes peuvent
subir c'est le ransomware qui est la
menace numéro une en matière de
cybersécurité en 2021 il ya aussi le
phishing qui consiste à envoyer des
fichiers mail fictifs à des utilisateurs
pour récupérer leurs données
personnelles
alors comment réagir quand on est
victime d'une cyberattaque
il serait préférable de débrancher le
câble ethernet du pc de manière
confinant va sur le pc ensuite il serait
préférable de aussi pas écouté les
instructions de l'assaillant et de
directement compte été contactée la cnil
comment se protéger en amont pour éviter
ces cyberattaques au maximum la première
étape est de savoir sécuriser son mot de
passe
nous sommes partis interrogés les
yvelinois pour mieux connaître leurs
habitudes
oui si ce mot de passe partout
parce que j'ai peur d'oublier certains
je pense qu'en mettant le même partout
chez sûr d'avoir vraiment les
applications importantes où il ya des
données sensibles par exemple gmail et
j'utilise un bon mot de passe ou pour
les applications que j'ai étudié s'est
régulièrement mais sinon les petites
applications
je mets souvent le même alors faut-il
changer de mot de passe ou pas créer un
mot de passe compliquée christine fraude
au professeur de management des systèmes
informatiques nous en dit plus il faut
pas choisir un deux trois quatre
on va choisir le prénom de ses enfants
ils font plutôt choisir un mot de passe
qui a au minimum 12 entre 10 à 12
caractères et qui comporte donc des
chiffres des lettres des caractères
spéciaux les mots de passe ils doivent
est unique on a souvent l'habitude
d'utiliser des mots de passe identique
pour des sites différents et ça c'est à
proscrire
il est important de se protéger contre
la cybercriminalité car les cyber
attaques se multiplient comme dans la
ville de wuwei qui a suivi une attaque
de rang sans logiciel le 29 janvier
dernier
restons avec les élèves du lycée jules
ferry à conflans sainte honorine qui à
présent ont choisi de traiter le sujet
du jeu vidéo fait de sa mauvaise
réputation qui perdure fifa
counter-strike league of legends
nombreux sont les yvelinois qui passent
du temps quotidiennement sur ces jeux
vidéo
les études sont maintenant nombreuses à
montrer des avantages de l'an pratique
si certains apporte une flexibilité
cognitive d'autres permettent d'acquérir
diverses connaissances
parce que la majorité des documentations
sont en anglais et le jeu vidéo est
assez basées sur les mathématiques par
exemple nous
améliorer notre réflexion notre
stratégie est encore nous rassembler
avec les autres autre avantage du jeu
vidéo
les intelligences artificielles
permettent de voyager et de découvrir le
monde
la réalité virtuelle est un marché en
croissance elle plonge son utilisateur
dans une réalité créée on a le jeu
développé par microsoft s'appelle flight
simulator qui est un jeu où on pilote un
avion et on peut réellement être dans
l'avion
à voir le cockpit est vraiment être
plongé dans le jeu vidéo et avoir cette
sensation de voyage l'époque actuelle
est marquée par des périodes de
confinement et de couvre-feu
conséquence le nombre de joueurs ont
augmenté de 11,3 pour cent en raison du
lien social à porter sert à un peu en
moins de s'émanciper un peu oublier le
stress des cours et les transports cela
permet aussi développer des relations
indirectes des avec des personnes
virtuel davantage avec les jeux
multijoueurs c'est vraiment qu'on est
connecté avec le monde entier et que ça
permet de pouvoir faire des rencontres
après l'annnonce du troisième confirmant
la vente de jeux vidéo pourrait
connaître un nouveau rebond depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire leurs ventes
auraient augmenté de 183 %
les cours d'éducation physique et
sportive qui se poursuivent maintenant
en extérieur pour les élèves sont de
nouveau autorisées dans les lieux
couverts et ce depuis le début de la
semaine une nouvelle preuve de
l'importance de pratiquer une activité
pour les plus jeunes même en temps de
qu'ovide les élèves du collège la
vaucouleurs à mantes la ville se sont
penchés justement sur cette question
bonjour je me présente je suis clair et
l'a donc à ce média au collège a
beaucoup aujourd'hui
vous présentons un reportage sur les
loisirs ont tant de collecte notre
journaliste cloud et l'isae farine on l
enquête auprès de la classe woods est le
principal bonjour alors nous avons
quelques questions à vous poser la
première pourquoi avez vous décidé de
garder la création est ouverte alors la
classe foot ça fait partie du projet
d'établissement ces univers pour
l'établissement c'est quelque chose
d'important
les jeunes sont des génies aussi des
clubs c'est important pour eux pouvoir
garder un minimum d'entraînement et de
pouvoir dans l'activité fille avec la
korrika protocole sanitaire avez vous
mis en place par le protocole sanitaire
pour la classe foule c'est surtout
d'éviter les contacts rapprochés
donc ça c'est plutôt le professeur qui
entraîne des coûts qui a mis en place le
protocole avec des exercices où il ya la
distance de sexualité ou palmas qui sont
et s'éloigner ses souks où je passe des
choses comme ça et la dernière est peu
optimiste pour aller retour d'un match
mais pas trop est-ce que l'image pouvant
reprendre que moi connaissez avant les
du public avec des contacts rapprochés
il faudra sans doute inventer d'autres
avec le point du match
merci beaucoup bon vous lavant denis a
bouleversé les habitudes quel est
l'appel de la proviseure aux
entraînements
l'impact de la commune sur nos
entraînements et bas les matchs iba 600
contacts ont fait moins de matches on
essaye de garder le mètre de distance
j'espère que ça va bientôt revenir les
contextes parce que c'est un élément
essentiel dans le football
du coup nos entraînements ce perturbés
malgré la copie de votre motivation
est-elle toujours rendez vous moi j'ai
toujours la motivation car j'aime trop
le foot
oui ma motivation reste la même j'aime
bien avec qui fait la section du coup je
vais continuer à faire du football à la
section fo des fois je suis en classe
j'attends que le moment de la section
j'adore le football j'aime bien mes
camarades la section ça sert à nous
améliorer pour que en club on soit plus
fort et qu'on prend du plaisir à jean
foot mais assez nos trois journalistes
aux personnes entendues mais je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée ayman
continuation
[Musique]
et notre édition spéciale ce même de la
presse se poursuit nous sommes à présent
avec frédéric bussot bonjour bonjour
professeur au lycée jules ferry de
conflans sainte honorine bonjour
également à deux de vos élèves sébastien
et florian qui ont accepté de répondre à
quelques quelques questions bonjour à
vous deux bonjour vous allez travailler
notamment sur quelques reportages qu'on
a pu voir en début d'édition travail
avec les équipes de tv 78 comment vous
avez vécu je vais poser la question
d'abord aux étudiants aux élèves comment
vous avez vécu cette expérience que vous
en avez pensé
alors pour le coup nous avons vraiment
aimé ce projet car nous apporter
beaucoup de choses
donc ça nous a permis par exemple la
prise de parole en public
vraiment aussi ce qui nous a apporté
c'est le fait de comment boire et
comment chercher des articles oui il
faut les trouver leur source et c'est
ensuite ça nous apparaît aussi découvrir
le monde donc le métier de journaliste
tout ce qu'ils avaient rien évidemment
donc l'écriture les plans a fait râler
montage etc
donc oui le projet de tv sony nous a
apporté beaucoup de choses six ans pour
vous de vous pencher sur la question des
médias du côté de l'enseignante à
présent un frédéric bisson pour pour
vous cette expérience et cette
sensibilisation aux médias le retour
vous pouvez en faire peut-être alors
parce que ça apporte essentiellement
c'était les idées du concret dans ce que
l'on fait au quotidien et pour les
autres pour les étudiants la possibilité
effectivement de réaliser quelque chose
qui sorte du cadre scolaire et
universitaire voilà ça s'inscrire est
vraiment dans un projet au long cours et
à et les quatre semaines sur lesquels on
a travaillé sur i-tele soit 118 ont été
particulièrement constructive
effectivement la sensibilisation à
l'actualité c'est quelque chose que vous
faites au quotidien avec avec vos élèves
on a commencé dès la rentrée 1
dès la fin septembre on a lancé
plusieurs activités autour de la lecture
de la presse parce qu'effectivement en
culture générale et expressions ça reste
un pan important de notre de notre
discipline et des programmes à aborder
donc oui dès la rentrée première année
de bts
on travaille dessus régulièrement chaque
semaine comment ça se passe concrètement
ce travail je réponds encore oui comme
vous le savez je vais passer la parole
après aux élèves également eovi vont
être acquis un peu comme être les
étudiant e en dès septembre à présenter
chaque semaine par groupes de six
individuellement mais par six un article
de leur choix paru dans les semaines
donc au fur et à mesure les articles
sont diversifier les sources se sont
précisées leur lecture s'est faite plus
critique et aujourd'hui on arrive à une
présentation d'articles choisi avec avec
pertinence avec discernement avec un
regard plus pointues sur sur ces
articles
donc c'est déjà la première la première
activité que nous avons menées on l'a
également comment dire complexifier ces
dernières semaines avec la réalisation
de mini revue de presse c'est à dire que
pendant les vacances d'hiver par exemple
les étudiants ont choisi une thématique
et ont cherché les articles
correspondant à cette thématique pendant
les quinze jours de vacances donc
réalisant ainsi des deux micros revue de
presse avant cette première année de
sensibilisation et de travail et là je
m'adresse cette fois-ci re aux étudiants
est ce que vous suiviez l'actualité
alors oui mais la différence
on suivait plutôt l'actualité avec les
réseaux sociaux on entame notamment
twitter
instagram ou même snapshots et depuis
notre entrée en bts du coup on a appris
à sa forme et avec des sites comme le
parisien le monde ou même encore
l'internaute et quel regard du coup vous
portez sur cette façon de s'informer un
petit peu différente pour vous c'est
plus enrichissant c'est complémentaire
le travail forcément du coup la manière
de s'informer différentes
mais c'est nous voulons mais du coup
d'avoir un regard différent sur sur la
manière de s'informer sur l'actualité
j'ai moi aussi vous entendre sur le
regard que vous portez sur le la presse
montmagny et de manière générale sur
l'information sur la façon dont elle est
traitée
comment vous percevez ces informations
là et quel regard vous portez on dit
souvent que le métier de journaliste est
pas forcément l'un des plus appréciés
avec quelques unes des autres
professions vous plus jeune qu'elle quel
regard vous portez là dessus alors pour
le coup moi au début quand j'ai commencé
à avant le bts du moins je pensais
vraiment que le métier de journaliste de
la presse est un peu quand même de se
saisir de pavant de mensonge mais il y
avait de fait news avait peu enfin il
manquait d'informations vraiment
importante
et du coup quand même dingue du 100 m va
apporter du coup un regard plutôt
positif et commercial la revue de presse
et le monde de l'information et 13 ans
dj sentent si je peux dire ce que pour
le coup qui nous a permis de découvrir
que il n'y a pas que chez nous stop des
problèmes mais aussi à l'international
dans les problèmes et ceci très
important pour la connaissance du monde
et notre job sur le travail
regarde des faits qui nous peut-être
c'est aussi un travail que vous engagez
et là je repose la question à
l'enseignante mais c'est un travail qui
va s'engager un petit peu alors on
essaye déjà de comment dire d'avertir
nos élèves et nos étudiants par rapport
à l'importance des sources la
vérification de leurs sources de
croisement des informations qu'ils
peuvent qu'ils peuvent obtenir par les
différents médias qui la consultent donc
c'est déjà une chose que l'on fait en
faire attention faire attention aux
sources dans le travail quotidien
lorsqu'ils ont à présenter un arctique
ou ce genre de choses il a fallu
effectivement retrouvé ses sources
savoir comment les cités et puis à la
question des faits que nous mais on
essaie d'aborder cela c'est au centre
d'actualités c'est pas si
facile que cela le professeur
documentaliste a un rôle essentiel
également dans ce travail et comment
vous vérifiez justement là cette fois ci
je m'adresse aux lycéens et aux
étudiants comment vous vérifiez votre
information lorsque vous recevez quand
vous voyez des flux d'information vous
prenez tout de suite cette information
pour argent comptant ou vous cherché à
en savoir un petit peu plus alors du
coup il ya différents moyens de vérifier
ces informations
déjà on va regarder un peu la réputation
du site si c'est un site qui est assez
connu comme par exemple le monde
on va se dire que l'information est
forcément un peu plus fiable et 6 à des
sites qui sont moins connus
on va chercher plusieurs fois enfin sur
plusieurs sources différentes de
l'information pour voir si les
informations concordent bien si tu
comptes me fier à ce qu'on a vu vos
sources d'information ça reste internet
principalement le journal papier a
encore un rôle à jouer ou pas le joindre
le papier plutôt ça on voit qu
énormément c'est surtout surtout sur
internet surtout sur internet radio
télévision - ondes radio télévision où
il journal de 20h et le 19 45 qui
restent qui reste finalement un petit
peu des moyens de s'informer pour vous
même si aujourd'hui tout passe forcément
par le numérique
peut-être une question à un petit peu
plus large aussi sur le traitement et
l'enseignement de ces questions-là
d'information des cours d'éducation à
l'information ça vous semble nécessaire
pour vous frédéric bisson pour que ce
soit mis dans le coup dans les
programmes des élèves
au delà de spécialisation je pense que
c'est nécessaire c'est nécessaire à tout
âge à tous niveaux scolaires c'est à
dire que ce sont des des sujets qu'on
aborde dès la primaire ont continué le
travail en collage de nombreux
enseignants sont engagés dans cette
éducation aux médias et à l'information
en liste est et et pour autant les
étudiants arrivent parfois en dombes et
en bts avec un regard sur la formation
qui va parfois être invités à tweeter ou
ce genre de l'information donc il faut
poursuivre la démarche parce qu'en fait
là je pense qu'il ya la maturité
d'étudiants qui rentrent en ligne de
compte
ils apprennent des choses en collège en
lycée et il faut vraiment poursuivre
cela en dans le supérieur puisque
formation du citoyen face à
nécessairement marne à une dernière
question pour sébastien et florian ce
travail sur les médias ou même tout
simplement le fait de s'informer de
manière plus large et pas uniquement sur
les réseaux sociaux vous allez le
poursuivre au delà de vos études même
par la suite ça va devenir un réflexe
pour vous c'était contraignant cette
année alors du coup stationner quand
même assez particulière du coup vu des
circonstances des christiane faire de la
crise sanitaire
ce qui nous permet un peu de être
quotidiennement recherche d'informations
de potentiel de peut-être qu'on vous
demande un couvre feu ou de 40 de
l'information mais pour le couvrir ce
problème m'a permis de me permettre
d'être beaucoup plus informés car
maintenant j'ai comme découvert
plusieurs plateformes ou d'information
et comment regarder l'information et
comment utiliser si je puis dire pour
vous aussi
oui c'est je suis d'accord avec ça on
cela permet vraiment de découvrir une
nouvelle manière de s'informer pouvoir
justement mieux suivre l'actualité
merci beaucoup tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette interview
merci encore d'avoir été avec nous et
merci à votre établissement plus
généralement à celui de mantes-la-ville
également
qui ont tous les deux travaillé sur
cette édition avec nos journalistes que
je remercie également mélanie poké et
justine brasier merci à vous je rappelle
au passage que la semaine de la presse
et des médias à l'école est donc en
train de s'achever partout en france
juste avant de refermer ce numéro
spécial du 7-8 week-end je voudrais vous
parler tout de même d'une campagne de
communication réalisée par des lycéennes
des lycéens de l'académie de versailles
dans le cadre de cette semaine des
médias à l'école ils viennent de
diffuser sur les réseaux sociaux et dans
les établissements scolaires plusieurs
affiches réalisées à partir de
témoignages le message
et si c'était toi une vidéo a également
vu le jour
regardez moi c'est l'uci j'ai envoyé une
photo à mon petit ami je lui faisais
confiance
et pourtant quand je suis arrivé lundi
matin au collège je me suis sentie juger
par les gens j'ai appris que ma photo
avait fuité sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai dû quitter le collège pour le reste
de la journée maintenant je suis en
seconde et cette histoire me suis encore
au lycée
ça m'a détruite moi c'est ma dit la
semaine dernière j'ai partagé sur un
star photomontage de la prof
d'histoire-géo nu ça fait à mes potes et
ça fait le tour du lycée
tout le monde y croyait la preuve que la
très mal pris et maintenant c'est super
dur pour al 2 / cours avec nous ça va
détruire moi c'est inès je ne voulais
pas sortir avec lui donc il a décidé de
raconter à ses amis qu'on avait couché
ensemble
même mes amis ne le croyais pas il m'a
créé une mauvaise réputation
la rumeur a circulé sur snapshot et j'ai
été catégorisés comme fille facile j'ai
arrêté d'aller à l'école après samassa
mais détruites
moi c'est sofiane je suis handicapé mais
également fans de réseaux sociaux je
poste régulièrement des photos sur mon
compte d'un spam et depuis peu des
camarades se moquent de mon handicap sur
mes photos
quand je vais au lycée c'est vraiment
devenu un supplice ça m'a détruit pour
booster une blague j'espère que les
ententistes et cinq minutes juste avec
mais pour la victime c'est pour toute sa
vie aujourd'hui céline usc sofiane
celui-ci 6 et 9 ans
voilà pour ce spot réalisé à
l'initiative de lycéens de l'académie de
versailles dans le cadre justement de la
semaine des médias à l'école et je vous
redonne ce numéro aussi si vous êtes
victime de cyber harcèlement 0 800 200
milles 0 800 200 milles vendredi
prochain vous retrouverez lots nord
sinoquet pour une nouvelle édition plus
classique du 7-8 week end à votre
journal d'information locale revient lui
à lundi dès 18h en direct avec grégory
canal et à très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]